one instance that i think was probably
is still to this day one of the most
egregious was uh michael brown i mean
they still are saying hands up don't
shoot they are still pushing his
rhetoric and agenda and that to me has
stimulated all of this fear and hate and
misinformation
and where you can just blatantly lie
about the police and it's just
acceptable you could say that the black
man had his hands up and was executed in
the middle of the street and and that's
totally fine even though the doj and
with a black president or black attorney
general found that the officer did
nothing wrong
you still can push that and that leads
to uh the jacob blakes that leads to
you know all of these other cases
on the written house one um the meme out
there seemed to be that this guy is a
white supremacist and if you listen to
half the media it was basically
he shot three black people he did not
shoot any black people this was a white
kid
shot white people
in self-defense the whole thing was
screwed up how do we get past some of
this stuff i mean how do we
show people this is just not true
well hopefully the people who want to be
informed will watch the trial at least
watch highlights of the trial and come
up with their own conclusion about what
happens because when you listen to the
mainstream reader you will be deceived
right they make the picture of this guy
and even to this day you see black lives
matter out protesting it at the verdict
it's like dude this was a white guy who
they considered a suspect and then you
have white victims you have a white
judge you have a white prosecutor you
have a white defensive team
what are y'all even talking about this
has nothing to do with black people this
has nothing to do with black in general
and if you want to make the argument and
say this is a white supremacist
a picture of white supremacy and
criminal justice which white people the
white people that died they didn't get
no i mean if you feel like they were
unlawfully shot they didn't get any
justice it's just it's just foolery it's
a they made a mockery and the sad part
is that they're willing to forego
the the rights of individuals the
constitutional rights of individuals
somebody's dignity martin luther king
died in an effort to help us understand
that we should all be treated equally
they are foregoing martin luther king
all of our ancestors all of the wars
that have fought just to push an agenda
in my opinion to sell advertisement and
fear this kid was never a white
supremacist and then they connected him
to the proud boys the vice president of
the proud boys who i think he went to
jail for burning the blm flag he's a
black man
he's the vice president or like the
chair of of a proud boys i have
interacted with problems all the time
and i've interacted with black ones
hispanic ones i was in la and they came
to one of my events to help do security
um just just on their own and most of
them were hispanic so it's like
it's a it's a it's a rhetoric that's
being pushed and i'm hoping that people
see the hypocrisy at minimum when he's
found not guilty at least go back and
say well
why he was found now guilty let me go do
some research instead of just blaming it
on the system so so going into some of
those other names obviously we don't
have to cover all them but because you
hit on some of the names that we've
heard a lot of over the last couple
years is there one particular one either
the trial or the events that unfolded
that you think was most egregious sort
of in the way police were treated or the
result of it or or whatever else
yeah i think i i think i mentioned a few
of them you know i kind of lumped a
couple of them together um one instance
that i think was probably
is still to this day one of the most
egregious was uh michael brown i mean
they still are saying hands up don't
shoot they are still pushing this
rhetoric and agenda and that to me has
stimulated all of this fear and hate and
misinformation
and where you can just blatantly lie
about the police and it's just
acceptable you could say that the black
man had his hands up and was executed in
the middle of the street and and that's
totally fine even though the doj and
with a black president or black attorney
general found that the officer did
nothing wrong
you still can push that and that leads
to uh the jacob blakes that leads to
you know all of these other cases that i
think some of which i speak about in the
book that leads to brianna taylor where
you could just make up that she was
sleeping in her bed you can just make up
she was an emt and they hit the wrong
house when she was on the search warrant
she was involved in a criminal
enterprise and unfortunately her
boyfriend shot a cop at the door and
they returned fire and she ended up
dying subsequently but you can just make
up the fact that jacob blake was doing
nothing wrong when he had a knife in his
hand and he was actually uh
trespassed from the area he was area
restricted because he had sexually
assaulted his baby mama he shows up she
calls the police he has a knife they
shoot him you can just blatantly say
that they shot him for no reason macar
bryan um they had gone away because they
they knew the girl was trying to stab
that other girl when she got shot by the
police you can blatantly say they gunned
down a 16 year old girl with no unarmed
and the people sitting there at the
scene
saw that she had the knife and they go
on tv and say she was unarmed because in
our society today because of michael
brown you can just make up whatever you
want and you can cry over it i mean that
is crazy to me that one when we've all
seen the video she's got the knife she
could basically either stab the other
girl or or decapitate her in that moment
and people are going oh he should have
shot the leg or he should have shot or
he should have used a taser etc etc it's
like like i guess at some level that
sort of makes sense like you don't want
to kill somebody obviously you don't
want to legally shoot somebody on the
other hand
the person who's about to be killed they
need to be saved they that was to me
that one because it was just so obvious
to be angry at that police officer who's
trying to save someone's life woke up
that morning did not know he was gonna
have to save someone's life
and and he's a freaking big ass knife
he's a hero i mean essentially he's a
hero i bet the parent of the girl that
was gonna get stabbed think i mean i i
don't know these days but you would
imagine that the parents think that he's
a hero i mean you gotta understand like
people have not been a police officer
the way he handled himself and the way
he was able to use force against only
that one person he hit nobody else he
used the amount of force necessary to
prevent her from killing the other girl
the guy was composed he did his dog-own
job um and it's a split-second decision
you got to think he sees a 16-year-old
girl but he also see another young lady
that needs her life saved and he did
what he had to do to make that happen
and lebron james come out and demonize
the man and it's like
listen dave this is a it's a bigger
problem than just misunderstanding like
there is an effort and ignorance within
a large population of our community uh
the black community and the community at
large of people just being dumb i mean
they don't do any research they don't
look at people still think
uh uh kyle renton has killed black
people like some people still
are saying black lives matter he
couldn't kill him black people
if people even after the due andrew i
think his name was andrew coffey
he was he got off the same day as kyle
reading house on a self-defense case
when he killed a police officer in a
swat raid
i believe the verdict was i mean i i
accept the verdict i didn't watch the
trial so i don't know if the verdict was
right or not according to my opinion but
i i accept it but you gotta they if he
was black if kyle really house was black
this wouldn't happen well you got a
black man right here that killed a white
i don't know if the cop was white but he
killed a police officer this is prime
real estate for the racist justice
criminal justice system to throw a black
man under the bus and he gets off on a
self-defense charge and
come on man like you can't give them
more evidence and they just don't
receive it
brandon i assure you that the pandemic
of dumb people has nothing to do with
anyone's skin color you know this is
this thing is across the system right
now absolutely across the system do you
sense that this is all ramping up again
it seems to me like you know we had all
the the riots and the blm stuff and the
antifa stuff before the election then we
sort of got the results that the
mainstream wanted okay joe biden's
president we had 10 months of nothing
then in the last month it seems like the
race stuff is starting to bubble up
again we get the kyle rittenhouse
verdict we get what happened just now in
wisconsin it feels like it's about to
all start again almost as if and i think
this is sort of what you're saying it's
kind of manipulated this isn't all
organic bubbling up from the bottom
frustrated kids
yeah if you think about it these
occurrences of police getting into
shootings with people shooting people
unarmed or whatever case would be this
is consistent every year there's nothing
new
funny thing is is when election time
comes around it's all of a sudden the
biggest thing that have ever happened to
us in world history i mean this is what
they make it out to be they did a
moderate barriers case uh and kyle
riddinghouse case almost simultaneously
and i think they did it for a purpose
because you had kyle rittinghouse which
i think that they wish that he was found
not guilty and they could have said look
white supremacy and then the mcmichaels
where they believe that they will be
found guilty which they did today um
they were going to say look white
supremacy these are two cases that they
can compile together to cause the world
to have a uproar for the next i don't
know how many months if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell